[MUSIC]
In 1949, Harry S Truman was tired.
World War II had just ended, and
in his second inaugural address,
Truman needed to inspire Americans,
weary after years of war.
To do it, he painted America
in a fresh and altruistic way.
He said, and I quote,
more than half the world's population
live in conditions approaching misery.
Their economic life is primitive and
stagnant.
We must embark on a bold new program for
the improvement and
growth of underdeveloped areas.
What Truman is saying here, is a powerful
new idea in the world, development.
If the West pulls our resources,
we can help poor developing
countries do just that.
Develop, get richer.
It's an uplifting narrative making
Americans feel good that we can help.
One small issue this was a total PR play.
It was a concept made up ten days prior
by a mid level State Department employee
whose only mandate was to reignite
American energy for Truman second term.
At the time of his speech,
not one document existed to support
the actual execution of the plan.
And to put this in historical context,
a western-led narrative at the time
of benevolence, was unprecedented.
Western-led colonialism was still
going on after World War II at
the time of the speech but Americans loved
the new narrative and we followed through.
And today the West, mainly US and
Europe give on average 130
billion in aid per year.
This is through large philanthropies
like the Gates Foundation,
through multi laterals like
the World Bank and IMF, and
through traditional government aid
like USAID or defit, in the UK.
And through our collective giving,
Truman's narrative has
stood the test of time.
Rich countries help poor countries,
it's something we all kind of know.
But for this idea to have legs, we need
to believe that it's in some way working,
that that 130 billion we give in aid
per year is having real impact and
the poor are getting less poor.
And that too is a widely touted narrative.
In 2015,
the UN published a landmark report
that said that the global poverty rate has
been cut in half over the last 30 years.
And that sounds great because that
means that our efforts are working and
our global economic system is sound.
And we should all feel good about
that if not for a difficult fact.
Global poverty isn't getting better,
in fact, it hasn't budged in 30 years.
So the 2015 claim of huge
wins against global poverty
relies on an antiquated
$2-a-day poverty line.
That poverty line is set by the same
institutions responsible for
showing progress against poverty,
and so that line is abysmally low.
Most development economists today cite
that it takes closer to an $8-a-day
poverty line to achieve basic nutrition
and normal human life expectancy.
And if we look at the $8-a-day
poverty line, and
subtract out China, which has
taken its own development efforts,
mostly outside of US control, we see
that the proportion of people living in
extreme poverty hasn't
meaningfully changed in 3 decades.
And we can see this reflected again in
our ever growing global inequality.
The gap in GDP per capita between rich and
poor countries has tripled since
the time of Truman speech.
Let that sink in.
This is not a tale of poor
countries catching up to the west,
this is a story of
a growing poverty divide.
For me,
this is a profound thing to grapple with.
I work in development economics, and
I've worked to expand access to credit for
the unbanked in emerging markets.
I lived between Peru and
Indonesia and Kenya and
I thought I was part of a wave of
things generally getting better.
The idea that global poverty is not
getting better hits me to my core
and it forces me to ask my
trillion dollar question.
In the face of all of
these development efforts,
why aren't we making
progress against poverty?
And in that, is the Western influence
I'm a part of helping or hurting?
My favorite development economist
Jason Hickel has a shocking idea.
What if aid, all the bridges,
all the bed nuts is irrelevant or
worse than irrelevant?
What if it is nothing more
than a convincing PR play?
Like Truman's speech, a distraction.
In this narrative,
we get to be the good guys.
The West is helping the poor catch up and
everyone gets to sleep at night knowing we
are doing what we can and we don't have
to do anything differently, besides maybe
give a little bit more in aid per year.
If our global economic system
is working to alleviate poverty,
but clearly, it's not working.
So what's going on here?
Why haven't we made progress against
poverty despite half a century of effort?
I want to put that $130 billion
in aid per year in perspective.
That's a big number.
But it's much smaller than
the value that flows in
the opposite direction from poor to rich.
In 2016, the Global Financial Integrity
Group published shocking data on
the ways that value is extracted
out of poor countries.
This is not trade flows but
ways that value is being transferred
sometimes illegally, from poor to rich.
So when Western governments give
loans to poor countries to the IMF,
we demand back substantial interest rate,
exorbitant interest rates.
And with the miracle of compound interest,
many poor countries are continuously
crippled under their debt burden.
Some of these debts were taken decades ago
and the principle has been long repaid but
we keep demanding back interest.
To put his debts in perspective,
the amount that poor countries spend
on debt service each year is a bigger
number than the UN projects as needed to
eradicate global poverty, completely.
And when we loan, on top of interest
we have structural adjustment.
So that's when Western governments
lend to poor countries,
we demand the poor countries
adopt certain economic policies.
And we tell them these policies
will help them develop but really,
these are policies of free trade and
low tariffs, that benefit our
Western corporations working there.
And most nefariously of all,
we have trade misinvoicing,
which is the very illegal yet very
prevalent practice of large corporations,
misreporting trade prices on our invoices
in order to avoid local government taxes.
There's a lot more ways the value
flows from poor to rich but
the point here is that our aid
budget is ridiculously small
compared to all the ways money is
gushing out of poor countries.
This is outrageous
especially because we've used our
tiny aid budget to fuel a cultural
narrative of our own benevolence and
that narrative hides
the patterns of extraction that
are actively keeping poor countries poor.
Maybe this isn't all that
surprising given centuries
of Western led extraction
under colonialism.
I would argue it's the same
extraction hidden behind a PR
band-aid of development.
I work in development, so
seeing these numbers is deeply troubling.
And to be clear, I don't think
development in and of itself is bad, but
it shouldn't be used as a cover-up for
extractive global economic
system imposed by the West.
And I've realized I need to get
my head up out of the sand and
look at this straight on if
I want to do any good and
if you want to join me,
there's places to start.
Large companies give lip service to
things like ESG through impact and
CSR, but
I think we need a new code of ethics.
So when you run large corporations in
the developing world, do basic things,
like pay your fair share of taxes and
demand the companies you work for do too.
And for all of us in the broader West,
I want to challenge us to rethink our role
in development and stop hiding behind
a narrative that the West is helping.
To be really blunt, if you're from
a rich country, your privilege was built
on the backs of those in poor countries
and continues to be built on them.
We have to get our story straight.
Which countries aren't
developing poor countries?
It's the other way around.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]